hi guys so today's session is on AWS
elastic beanstalk
so what's in it for you today we'll be
discussing about what is AWS why we
require AWS elastic beanstalk
what is AWS elastic beanstalk the
advantages disadvantages the components
of mean stock along with that the
architecture and the companies that are
primarily using these aw spin stock so
let's get started and first understand
what is AWS Hero pious stands for Amazon
Web Services it's a cloud provider and
that offers a variety of services such
as compute power database storage
content delivery and many other
resources so we know that AWS is the
largest cloud provider in the market and
so many services are available in the
AWS where you can apply the business
logics and create the solutions using
the cloud platforms now ye W is elastic
means talk now what happened earlier and
that whenever the developer used to
create the software or the modules
related to the software's has to be
joined together to create a big
application now one developer creates a
module that has to be shared with
another developer and if the developers
are geographically separated then it has
to be shared over a medium probably an
internet so that is going to take some
time it would be a difficult process and
in return it makes the application or a
software development a linear process
the building of the software development
linear process so there were challenges
which the developers were facing earlier
and to overcome that we have the
Beanstalk as a service available in the
AWS so why AWS elastic Beanstalk is
required
AWS elastic beanstalk has made life of
the developers quite easy in terms of
that they can share the applications
across different devices at a shorter
time duration now let's understand what
ICW is elastic beanstalk irritability
lasting mean stock is a service which is
used to deploy and scale web
applications by developers not only web
application any application that is
being developed by the developers this
is a symbol representation of the AWS
lasting in stock now along with
that the AWS elastic Beanstalk supports
the programming language the runtime
environments that are java.net PHP
node.js Python Ruby go and docker and in
case if you are looking for any other
programming language or a runtime
environment and then you can make a
request with AWS to arrange that for you
now what are the advantages associated
with the elastic means talk first
advantages that it's a highly scalable
service now when we talk about the
scalability it means that whenever we
require the resources in demand we can
scale up the resources or we can scale
down the resources so that is kind of a
flexibility we get in terms of changing
the type of resources whenever we need
it and in that case the elastic
Beanstalk is a highly scalable service
now that is something which is very
difficult to achieve in case often on
Prem environments because you have to
plan for the infrastructure and in case
if you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second advantage
associated with the Beanstalk is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple that means
that you just have to focus on the
development of an application building
an application and then you can just
deploy the application directly using
the Beanstalk what the Beanstalk is
going to do that every networking aspect
has been taken care by the Beanstalk it
deploys your application in the backend
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the URL or
through the IP address the third
advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we discussed in
the fast and simple to begin as well so
why it offers a quick deployment you
don't have to bother about the
networking concepts you just have to
focus on the application development and
then you can just upload your
application deploy that and then you are
good to go the other advantage is that
it supports multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or multi
talents that means we can have a virtual
environments for separate organizations
or the divisions within the
organizations that will be virtually
isolated so likewise you can have
virtually isolated environments created
on the Beanstalk and they can be
separated used as a separate entities or
a separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
since it's a scalable then it is a
flexible also now coming to the
simplifies operations as an advantage
now once the application is deployed
using the Beanstalk then it becomes very
easy to maintain and support that
application using the Beanstalk services
itself and the last advantage that we
can have from the Beanstalk is that it's
a cost-efficient service the cost
efficient as we know that many of the aw
services are cost effective the cost
optimization can be better managed using
the AWS main stock as compared to if you
are developing or if you are deploying
any kind of an application or a solution
on the on-prem servers now there are
some components that are associated with
the AWS Beanstalk and it has to be
created in the form of a sequence manner
so it obviously means to consist of few
important components which are required
while developing an application now what
are these components these are four
components one is application the second
is application version the third is
environment and the fourth one is the
environment there and we have to
progress while deploying our
applications or the software's using the
same sequence now let's understand what
are the different components of the
Beanstalk are the application it refers
to a unique label which is used as a
deployable code for a web application so
generally you deploy your web
application or you create your
application and that is something which
is basically used as a unique label then
the second component is application
versions so it resembles a folder which
stores a collection of components such
as environments versions and environment
configurations so all these components
are being stored using the application
version the third most important
component is the environment in the
environment only the current versions of
the applications runs now remember that
elastic means talk supports multiple
versions as well and using the
environment you can only run the current
version of the application for if you
wanted to have another version of an
application to be running then you have
to create an another environment for
that then comes the environment here and
in the environment here it is basically
it designates the type of application
that the environment runs on now
generally there are two types of
environment here one is the web and the
other one is the worker node and
something which we'll be discussing
later as well now let's understand how
does elastic Beanstalk in AWS works
so first we have to create an
application and this is a task that
would be done by the developers and for
that you can actually select any runtime
environment or a programming language
like Java docker ruby gopal or python as
well and once you select that
environment you can develop your
application using that runtime in
valance
now after that once the application is
created then you have to upload the
version of an application on the AWS and
after that once the version is uploaded
and then you have to launch your
environment so just have to click on on
the buttons that's it nothing more you
have to do once the environment is
launched then you can actually view that
environment using a web URL or using the
IP address now what happens in that case
is when you launch an environment in the
backend the elastic Beanstalk neurons
automatically runs an ec2 instance and
using a metadata the Beanstalk deploys
our application within that ec2 instance
that is something which you can look
into the ec2 dashboard as well so you
don't have to take care of the security
groups you don't have to take care of
the IP addressing and even you don't
have to login into the instance and
deploy your application it would be done
automatically by the Beanstalk it's just
that you just have to monitor the
environment and the statistics will be
available there itself in the Beanstalk
dashboard otherwise you can view those
statistics in the cloud watch logs as
well now in case if you wanted to update
any kind of a version then you just
upload a new version and then just apply
that and then monitor your environment
so these are the essentials to create a
local applications for any platform
whether it's a node.js Python etc these
are the things that you have to actually
take care and this is the sequence you
have to follow while creating an
environment so you can say that it's a
four steps creation of our or deployment
of your application that's it now after
users upload their versions the
configuration is automatically deployed
with a load balancer yes and with a load
balancer that means you can access the
applications using the load balancer DNS
also and apart from load balancer if you
wanted to put any other feature that
includes the auto scaling
for example if you wanted to create your
ec2 instances where the application will
be deployed within the virtual private
cloud or in a particular subnet within
the V PC all those features that are
available and you can select them using
the Beanstalk itself you don't have to
move out to the V PC you don't have to
actually go to the ec2 dashboard and
select all those separately
everything would be available within the
Beanstalk dashboard so that's what it
says in the presentation that after
creating an application the deploy
service can be specifically accessed
using the URL so once the environment is
created there will be a URL defined now
you can put a URL name also and that is
something which you wanted to put for
your application you can define that you
can check for the availability of that
URL and then you have to use that URL to
access your application or the browser
now once it is done then in the Monitor
environment it says the environment is
monitored provided capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and in Malta
features all those features are
available there itself in the mean
stocks now let's understand at the
architecture of AWS elastic Beanstalk
now there are two types of environments
that you have to select you can select
one is the web server environment and
the other one is the worker environment
so based on the client requirement
Beanstalk gives you two different types
of environment that you have to select
generally the web server environment is
the front end facing that means the
client should be as accessing this
environment directly using a URL so
mostly a web applications are deployed
using that environment the worker
environment is the backend applications
or the micro apps which are basically
required to support the running of the
web applications now it depends on the
client requirement what kind of an
environment you wanted to select now in
the web server environment it only
handles the HTTP request from the client
so that's why we use the web server
environment mostly for the web
applications or any application which
works on the HTTP HTTP requests so it's
not only the HTTP you can use the HTTP
ssible the worker environment it process
background tasks and minimizes the
consumption of resources so again it is
just like kind of a micro service or an
application services that are running in
the backend to support the web server
environment now coming to the
understanding of the AWS means talk so
this is how the architecture of the AWS
Beanstalk is designed and you can refer
to that image also
now in the web server environment let's
say if we select the web server
environment and it says that if the
application receives client requests the
Amazon route 53 sense is request to the
elastic load balance now obviously we
discussed here that the web server
environment is primarily an environment
which receives the HTTP requests it's a
kind of a client facing environment
now if the application receives a client
request our mazhab from the Amazon route
53 this route 53 is a service which is
primarily used for DNS mapping it's a
global service and it am a route you can
route the traffic from the route 53
matching your domains towards the load
balancer and from the load balancer you
can point that traffic to the web server
environment obviously the web server
environment is nothing it's just the ec2
instances that would be running in the
backend now here in the diagram you can
see that there are two web server
moments and they are created in the auto
scaling group that means there is some
kind of scaling options that are defined
as well and these instances are created
in an availability so more they can be
created in a different availability zone
also for the redundancy as well and
these web application servers are
further connected to your databases
which primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
RDS database also so all these
functionalities all these features are
basically available on the elastic
Beanstalk dashboard itself now what
happens in that case is if the
application receives client requests
Amazon is route 53 send these requests
to the load balancer later the load
balancer shares those requests among the
ec2 instances how does that happen it
happens using a predefined algorithm the
equal distribution of a load is
distributed to both the ec2 instances or
n number of ac2 instances running in the
available zone now in the availability
zones every ec2 instance would have its
own security group they can have a
common security group also they can have
their own security group as well now
after the security group the load
balancer is then connected to the Amazon
ec2 instance which are part of the auto
scaling group so that's something which
we have discussed already
now this auto scaling group is would be
defined from the Beanstalk itself and
there will be some scaling options that
will be created it could be a
possibility that it might be the minimum
number of instances that would be
running as of now and based on the
threshold affiant it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the
load balancer will keep on distributing
the load to as many instances that will
be created inside the availability
source obviously there will be an
internal hell check that the load
balancer will be first doing before
distributing the real-time traffic to
this instances created by the Beanstalk
now what the sort of scaling group does
it automatically starts the additional
ec2 instance to accommodate increasing
load on your application that's
something which we know that and also it
monitors and scales instances based on
the workload as well so depends on what
kind of a scaling threshold you have
defined in the auto scaling groups and
when the load of an application
decreases the ec2 instance will also be
decreased so whenever we talk about the
auto scaling generally it comes in our
mind is that we scale up the resources
that means we it increases the ec2
instances in the auto scaling you might
have this scaled down option also scale
down policy also created in which if the
load minimizes it can terminate the
additional ec2 instances as well so that
is something which will be automatically
managed all these features can be
achievable using the elastic beanstalk
and with this feature accommodated it
gives you the better cost optimization
in terms of managing your resources now
it says that elastic Beanstalk has a
default security group and the security
group acts as a firewall for the
instances now here in this diagram it
says about the security group
auto-scaling also you might create it in
a default VPC also you might create it
in your custome PC also where you can
have the additional level of security is
also created you can have the NAC else
knuckles also defined here before the
security groups so that would give you
the additional filtering option or the
firewall option now it says that with
these groups with these security groups
it allows establishing security groups
to the database server as well so every
database would also have its own
security group and the connection can be
created between the web servers
environment and that is created by the
Beanstalk to the database security
groups as well now let's discussed about
the worker environment now understanding
the worker environment what happens is
that the client the webserver
environment is the client facing the
client sends a request for an access to
the web server and in this diagram the
web server further sends it to the SQS
which is a simple queue service and the
queue service
which to the worker environment and then
whatever the worker environment is
created for doing some kind of a
processing or some kind of an
application that is running in the
backend that environment initiates and
then sent back the results to this sqs
and my server so so let's understand the
architecture of our aw silastic means
talk with the worker environment so when
a worker environment here is launched aw
lastic Beanstalk and saw the server on
every ec2 instance so that is in the
case of a web server environment also
and later the server passes the request
to the simple queue service now this
service is an asynchronous service
instead of a simple queue service you
can have other services also it is not
necessary that you need to have the sqi
so so this is an example that we are
discussing about and the sqs shares
those message via a post request to the
HTTP path over the booker environment
and there are many case studies also
with respect to this kind of an
environment that is being created that
has been done on many customers and you
can search for this kind of a case
studies available on the Internet
now the worker environment execute the
tasks given by the SQS with the HTTP
response after the operation is
completed now here what happens is a
quick recap the client requests for an
access of an application to a web server
using an HTTP request the web server
passes that request to the queue serves
the queue service shares the message
with the worker probably a worker might
be the manual worker generally it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
via the worker environment only and the
worker sends back the response with the
HTTP response back to the queue that
response can be viewed that a clip from
the queue service by the client using
the web server so this is one of the
example likewise I as I said that there
can be many other examples also ways you
can have the worker environments
different now what are the companies
that are using the elastic Beanstalk
these are few of the companies and that
are primarily using zillow jelly
button-- games then you have League of
Women Voters
Ebury these are some of the few listed
companies and obviously you search on
the ALW site and you find many more
organizations that are using the elastic
Beanstalk primarily for
deploying their applications now the
next thing is to go with the practicals
that how actually we use the elastic
beanstalk
so let's look into the demo using the
AWS elastic beanstalk now first you have
to login into the AWS console and i'm
sure that you might be having the
accounts created or you can use the IM
credentials as well and then you have to
select the region also now I am in the
North Virginia region likewise you can
select any of the regions that are
listed here now click on the services
and you have to search for the elastic
Beanstalk you can find the elastic
Beanstalk under the compute section so
here itself you will find the elastic
Beanstalk as a service now open this
service and there it will give you an
option to create an environment you have
to specifically select an environment
properly a worker environment or a web
service environment so let's wait for
the service to open so we have the - put
now available with us this is how the
elastic Beanstalk looks and this is the
symbol representation for Beanstalk now
what do you have to do is we have to
click on get started and that will load
and you have to create a web app so
instead of creating a web app what we
will do we will create a new application
so just click on create a new
application put an application name
let's say we put something like X Y Z
you can put any description to your
application let's say it's a demo app
and click on create now it says you have
to select an environment now the
environment the application name X Y Z
is greater you just have to select the
nav environment so click on create one
now and it is going to ask you that what
kind of an environment here you want it
to select so as we discuss that there
are two types of environments one is the
web server and the other one is the
worker in one let's look into it what is
defined by the AWS ewc is that it has
two types of environment tiers to
support different types of web
applications web servers are standard
applications that listen for and then
process HTTP request typically over port
number 80 workers are specialized
application that I have a background for
processing tasks that listens for
message on an Amazon sqs queue workers
application post those messages to your
application by using HTTP response so
that's what we saw in the case of the
Beanstalk slides also now
the usability of our worker environment
can be anything now we'll do a demo for
creating a web server environment so
just click on select and you we have the
environment name created now we can
define our own domain it ends with the
region dot elastic Beanstalk calm let's
say I look for a domain which is XYZ
only that's the environment name now
I'll check for the availability whether
that domain name is available with us or
not and it says we don't have that
domain name so probably I will try to
make it with some other name and let's
look for the availability XYZ ABC and it
says yes it is available now once I
deploy my application I would be able to
access the application using this
complete DNS so you can put a
description it's demo app that we are
creating and then you have to define a
platform as well now these are the
platforms that are supported by the EWS
let's say I wanted to run a nodejs
environment so I just click on the knows
node.js platform the application codes
is something which is basically
developed by the developers and you can
upload the application right now or you
can do that later as well
once the environment is ready now either
you can select to create an environment
if you wanted to go with all the default
settings otherwise if you wanted to
customize it more you can click on
configure more options so let's click on
configure more options and here you
would be able to define various
different features like the type of an
instance for example what kind of an ec2
instance or a server that should be
running so that the Beanstalk can deploy
our applications over it if you wanted
to modify just click on a modify button
and here you can modify your instances
with respect to the storage as well now
apart from that if you wanted to do some
modification in the case of monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security or in the case of a capacity
let's look into the capacity so here you
can actually do the modification so in
the capacity you can select the instance
type also by default it is T 2 dot micro
but in case if your application requires
a larger type of an instance then you
can actually go for the instance type as
well similarly you can define your EMI
IDs also because obviously for the
application to run you would require the
operating system also so you can select
that particular ami ID for your
operating system as well let's cancel
that likewise you have many other
features that you can actually define
here from the dashboard and you don't
have to go to the ec2 dashboard to do
the modifications now let's go and
create an environment let's assume that
we are going with the default
configuration so this is going to create
our environment the environment has been
created and you can get the environment
and the logs define in the dashboard
itself so you see that the Bienstock
environment is being initiated the
environment is being started and in case
if there would be any errors or if it is
deployed correctly you get all the logs
here itself now the environments are
basically color coded so there are
different color codings that are defined
if you get the environment in a green
color that means everything is good to
go so here you can see that it has
created an elastic IP it has checked the
health of the environment now it has
created the security groups and that
would be an auto security groups created
by the main stock and the environment
creation has been started you can see
that elastic Beanstalk as Amazon s3
storage bucket for our environment data
as well this is the URL through which
you will be accessing the environment
but right now
we cannot do that since the environment
is being created let's click on the
application name and here you can see
that it is in a grey color that means
right now the build is me done it has
been created once it will be
successfully created it should change to
the green color and then we will be able
to access our environment using the URL
now if I move to the ec2 instances and
see in the ec2 dashboard if I see
whether the instance is being created by
the Beanstalk or not so let's see and
let's see what are the differences in
terms of creating an instance manually
and getting it created from the
Beanstalk so click on Dec 2 let's go to
the oldc to experience that's what we
are familiar with and let's see what's
there in the dashboard
so here you can see one running instance
let's open that and the XYZ environment
which was created from the Beanstalk is
being initiated the instance is being
initiated and that is something which is
being done by the Beanstalk it's said we
have not gone to the dashboard and
created it manually now in the security
groups if you see that here the AWS
means talk security groups are defined
it has the elastic IP is also defined so
everything is being created by the
Beanstalk itself right now let's go back
to the Beanstalk and let's look into
this status of our environment whether
the color-coding has been changed from
grey to in green or not and here you can
see the environment is successfully
created and we have that environment
colored in green will access the
environment and it says it's a web
server environment its platform is
node.js running on 64-bit Amazon Linux
ami and it's a sample app sample
application health status is ok now the
other thing is that if you do not want
to use the web console the management
console to access the main stock then
the Beanstalk offers you the elastic
Beanstalk CLI as well so you can install
the command-line interface and then you
have the command reference of CLI
command references that you can actually
play with and get your applications
deployed using the Beanstalk itself so
this is one of the sample CLI commands
that you can actually look into now
let's look into the environment let's
click on the environment and we be
represented with the URL it says health
is OK these are the logs that you have
to follow in case if there are any
issues the platform is no deist that is
what we selected now the next thing is
you just have to upload and deploy your
applications so just click on upload and
deploy select the version label or the
name select file and wherever your
application is hosted add just select
that upload it and deploy your
application you see that the like your
environment is created similarly your
application will be deployed
automatically on the instance and from
this URL you will be able to view the
output it is as simple as just like you
have to follow these four steps now
let's see whether the node.js
environment is running on our instance
before deploying an application so we'll
just click on this URL since
the Beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or HTTP port 84 all we
can actually view that output directly
from the URL so we have the node.js
running that's visible here and after
that you just have to upload and deploy
our application and then from that URL
you can get the output now this URL you
can map it with the route 53 service so
using the route 53 DNS services the
domain names can be pointed to the
elastic Beanstalk URL and from there it
can be pointed to the applications that
are running on the ec2 instance whether
you wanted to point it to the URL
directly using the Beanstalk you can do
that otherwise as we saw in the slides
you can use the route 53 pointer to the
load balancer and then point it to the
instances directly also once it is
created by the Beanstalk so that was the
demo guys with respect to the Beanstalk
and how we can actually run the
environments apart from that the
operational tasks like system operations
you can manage all these things from the
environment dashboard itself so you have
the configurations you have the logs you
can actually check the health status of
your environment you can do the
monitoring and you can actually get the
alarms and the events here so let's say
if I wanted to if I wanted to see the
locks I can request for the locks here
itself and I'll be represented with the
full log report and I can now download
that log file and I can view the locks
so it's in D so we have this bundle
locks in the zip file alright so if you
want to see some kind of logs with
respect to elastic beanstalk activity
it's in the form of a notepad and here
you can see what all configurations the
Beanstalk has done on your environment
on your instance similarly you can go
for the health monitoring alarms events
and all those things fine guys so that
was with respect to the elastic
Beanstalk demos and catch you guys in
the upcoming sessions as well thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here